alfie evan struggles for life North
Korea and South Korea meet and we check
the mail back this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so there's a lot of news today some of
it I think quite frustrating I'm more
frustrated with the news I think today
that a lot of other people are on the
right I'll explain why that is in just a
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at texture so you are
addicted to information you are and
that's why you listen to this podcast
that's why I talk so fast because I like
conveying information well if you are
addicted to information then there's one
app you need and that is the people over
a texture right their texture app is
just fantastic you're reading more than
then you could possibly imagine when
you're stuck at an airport and you've
run out of reading material and now you
take your iPad well what do you have to
do have subscribed to seven eight
magazines instead you have the texture
app and it gives you unlimited access to
over 200 top magazines including people
the Atlantic Time Vanity Fair okay I've
actually gotten guests on this show from
reading some of the magazines that I
subscribe to with texture with texture
again you get unlimited access to those
200 top magazines and all their back
issues in a single app so anytime you
want to explore one you can and if you
sign up right now at texture comm slash
pen you actually got a 7 day free trial
again to start that free trial go to
texture comm slash pen you can start
reading the latest issues of your
favorite magazines today there's a
reason that there are so many of these
magazines that are increasing
circulation the in-depth reporting at
places like New Yorker which is included
in the texture app it's just top-notch
texture calm slash Ben it's a place to
go when you want your 7 day free trial
oh access to over 200 top magazines
textured calm / ben if you're an
information junkie there's no better app
texture calm / Ben go check it out and
use that / Ben so they know that we sent
you okay so the latest in the Alfie
Evans case from Great Britain so I
wanted to talk a little bit about a
counter argument that's being made with
regard to Alfie Evans you'll recall that
Alfie Evans the 23 month old baby who
has an undiagnosed brain condition a
degenerative brain condition that has
left him with apparently 30% brain
function and his parents want to take
him out of Great Britain and bring him
to Italy for experimental treatments and
the British government has said no he
must die here in this hospital they have
now removed him from life support he's
now going on and believed three days
without life support they said he was
gonna die right away and now he's still
alive right he's still breathing
apparently his dad has been giving him
mouth-to-mouth in the hospital let's
just start with this if mom and dad were
at home and they had a kid with a brain
condition and they were deliberately
refusing that kid water they would be
brought up on charges of child abuse and
past
homicide instead because this is being
done in a hospital everybody says that
it's okay
but now alfea's family has issued a
statement okay the the statement is this
note to supporters asking them to stand
down as they negotiate with the hospital
why because apparently according to the
UK Telegraph alfea's doctors told
reporters that Alfie's parents must make
a sea change in their attitude toward
the medical system holding their son
hostage quote instead the judge said at
the best alfea's parents could hope for
was to explore the options of removing
him from intensive care to either a ward
a hospice or his home but a doctor
treating Alfie who cannot be named for
legal reasons said that for Alfie to be
allowed home would require a sea change
in attitude from the child's family and
they feared that in the worst case they
would try to take the boy abroad I mean
there's an astonishing claim that
somehow the parents have to evidence a
sea change in their attitudes their kid
who's dying can wet when alfie dies
which she probably will when Alfie dies
it will not be any of these doctors
visiting his grave it will not be any of
the bureaucrats who the judge is
visiting his grave it'll be out the
evidences parents who are going there to
bring flowers and pray for him
apparently devout Catholics this idea
that they have to change their attitude
toward the government demonstrates once
again that this is all about treating
the government is God not at all about
the best interests of the child say
Alfie's parents have now told me on
Thursday afternoon they plan to meet
without these doctors as soon as
possible
Alaa Raheja Hospital withdrew Alfie's
life support on Monday the child has
survived breathing on his own with only
minimal help since then so according to
the the statement from Kate James and
Tom Evans the parents at sea I wish to
make a statement on behalf of myself and
Kate our lives have been turned upside
down by the intense focus on Alfie and a
situation our little family along with
out there has become the center of
attention for many people around the
world it is meant we have not been able
to live our lives as we would like we're
very grateful and we appreciate all the
support we've received from around the
world including from our Italian and
Polish supporters who have dedicated
their time and support to our incredible
fight we would now ask you to return
back to your everyday lives and allow
myself Kate and alder hate a former
relationship build a bridge and walk
across it sounds like a hostage
statement it sounds like a hostage
statement the UK healthcare system is
holding this kid hostage and holding the
parents hostage unless they're nice
about things so what is the count what
does the counter kazigos try and take
the the best possible counter case being
presented by the by medical left in
britain so their case is that alfie is
suffering by being alive and the best
thing that can happen for him is to die
quickly
and quietly in the most humane possible
fashion right this is really the case
that they are making the making the case
for euthanasia of Alfea or at least the
case for removing him from life support
the difference between euthanasia and
removal from life support is of course
the level of activity undertaken by the
doctors in euthanasia then they give you
a cocktail of drugs and you die in this
particular case there was throwing life
support and hoping that Alfie dies
quickly I mean I don't mean that
facetiously they are hoping that Alfie
dies quickly and in his little pain as
possible
there's a phrase that's been kicked
around by a lot of folks on the on the
medical left and in the bureaucracy in
Britain and it's a phrase that's been
repeated now by the judge in this
particular case it's been repeated by
the staff at elder hay Hospital it's
been repeated by NHS doctors writing for
the UK Guardian and that is Death with
Dignity which is a euthanasia phrase
Death with Dignity okay so here for
example the hospital said that their
goal was to kill Alfie with dignity
judge Hayden who's the person IDing
judge in this case talks similarly of
dignity and NHS doctor named Rachel
Clarke wrote in an op-ed for the UK
Guardian quote withdrawal of care is
neither killing nor murder but enables a
patient to die with comfort and dignity
so we have to actually we have to
actually distinguish between two
particular terms one is comfort and the
other is dignity now it is possible to
objectively determine whether someone is
going to die in more or less comfort
yeah I can tell that as a third party
and my wife works at a hospital we're
talking about this case yesterday and
she was talking about you know some of
the ways that people that she's seen
people's eye and they are horrific
they're absolutely horrendous I mean
there there are certainly cases in which
people would have died with more comfort
if they'd been moved to a hospice two
weeks before their death and then been
given morphine as they as they
transition from life right I mean that
would be the there's no question that
people died in a myriad range of
unfortunate and horrifying ways so if
your top priority is somebody time with
comfort then you can say okay want Alfie
to die with comfort and the experimental
treatment will be too painful
and so we're arguing with the parents
that they are not keeping the best
interest of the child at heart because
what they really are doing is extending
the they're not extending his chances of
getting better
they're making him suffer more and we
don't want him to suffer more so our
best interests are more aligned with the
best interest of the child that argument
I don't think is is a dispositive one I
don't even think it's a particularly
good one but I do think that it's an
argument that is that has some merit
some weight because again I can assess
as a third party whether you are in
comfort or whether you're not in comfort
anyone can tell that but dignity is a
different thing when the left has been
equated comfort and dignity for a while
and this is a materialistic conception
of what life constitutes right if you
believe that comfort and life and
dignity in life are the same thing
or comfort and death and dignity and
death are the same thing then that's a
pretty materialistic vision of what
exactly life is because dignity then is
boiled down to the level of physical
comfort you are experiencing at any
given time right that if you are a
person who's on your deathbed and you
choose to suffer all the way through
your last moments because you want to
cling to life because you think life is
just that important and you think that
it is important that your children know
that you struggled all the way to your
last breath
because you think that life is worth
clinging to and you should never give up
even when the situation is hopeless if
that's a lack of that's a lack of
dignity according to some people on the
left because the most dignified thing
would be just die in comfort because
comfort and dignity are the same thing
but obviously they are not the same
thing hey death with comfort again is
something that can be objectively
determined and we can know that a woman
who's dying on Val obstruction and is
choking on her own on her own stool
right we can we know that that person is
dying with less comfort but can you
honestly say that person is dying with
less dignity I'm not sure that you can
because dignity is a state of mind
relative to both yourself and to others
right if you treat yourself in dignified
fashion that means that you are acting
in accordance with your own personal
values that's I think the definition of
dignity with regard to yourself that you
have a set of values and you are
standing by those no matter what the
risk that is that is the definition of
dignity in accordance with yourself
dignity with regard to others is how
well you maintain your your standard of
stolidity in the face of serious pain
whenever we talk about the kind of stiff
British upper lip that's what they're
talking about they're talking about that
that sort of dignity they're not talking
about comfort they're talking about how
much suffering can you take without
actually without actually becoming a
burden on others and talking about an
emotional burden on others but to equate
comfort and dignity is a real mistake
because great men and women die in
horrible agony on a regular basis great
men and women very often are trying to
make a point by dying in agony that they
don't actually want to they don't
actually want to give up I'm like life
is more than just the level of physical
comfort they're experiencing at a given
time dying with comfort
be a term that's applicable to this baby
right would say Alfie you might say that
you know maybe Alfie should die and more
comfort than his parents want him to die
in time with dignity doesn't apply
because Alfie is 23 months old he
doesn't have the capacity to act in
accordance with his own virtuous ideas
because
Alfie's a baby right so that means that
he can't act in accordance with that and
as far as dignity with regard to others
that also doesn't really apply to Alfie
because the question now is whether his
parents or the state get to determine
what dignity looks like rights as the
state gets determined that its version
of dignity ie comfort is the governing
standard or do his parents get to
determine what dignity looks like maybe
they think dignity looks like you fight
for life all the way until your end of
your life no matter what the
consequences okay well that is certainly
an open question that's certainly a
question that's that's subjective in
nature there's no hard standard as to
whether the state is right or whether
his parents are right in their
definition of dignity and when in doubt
you got to go with the parents because
the parents again are the ones who care
more about Alfie there's a famous story
about Phil Gramm Phil Gramm is a senator
former senator from Texas in the United
States and and Phil Gramm apparently had
an exchange he liked to tell about with
this one leftist woman where he was
saying to her listen the the basis for
my entire politics is that I care more
about my children than you do and the
woman said that's not true and he said
really what are their names
okay that is certainly applicable here
as much as the judge says that he cares
about the child there's no as a parent
there's no one on earth who cares as
much about my child as my wife and I do
no one right now grandparents not
siblings no one until you've been a
parent and experienced the bond that
comes along with having a child for
anyone to step in between that bond for
a subjective reason like your definition
of dignity is just absurd and it's also
a fistic again there's a reason that
advocates of euthanasia like to use
death with dignity rather than death
with comfort because they understand
that if they use death with dignity then
they're making the implicit argument
that you choosing to go out on on
morphine is a more dignified death that
it's morally superior death comfort is a
morally neutral term because comfort is
morally neutral we know people who live
in comfort some bad people some are good
people doesn't comfort is not a moral
it's not a moral status dignity is and
there's a reason why the left keeps
using that misnomer
with regard to cases like Alfie Evans
they really should not they really
really should not it's a huge huge
mistake
so yeah again I think that that there's
no question that this should be left to
the parents and it's an egregious
miscarriage of justice that it's not
particularly because again the doctors
are assessing the situation then even
know it's wrong with Alfie so that's
that's the second factor here is that
even even if you assume alfie is gonna
die they see back to the parents the
state doesn't even know that Alfie is
going to die they say they do but they
really don't know because he's been on
off life support longer than they
thought he would be okay before I go any
further I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at Enzo chinos so nothing
makes you look better than a well fitted
suit if you're a dude and you want
you're going on a date or a big business
meeting coming up you know there's
nothing that makes you look better than
a custom fitted so you look like James
Bond
well that's what Enzo Chino is therefore
they're the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company they've
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes and Fast Company
they make suits and shirts made to fit
your exact measurements for a fantastic
fit and it's a you pick your own fabric
you can personalize the detail you can
personalize the lapel the lining the
monogram okay it's really cool you can
go to a showroom or shop online in Indo
Chino comm they have a bunch of
showrooms in a bunch of major cities
I've been down to their showroom and in
Los Angeles it is really cool it makes
you feel like you're walking into into
James Bond's men washout looks like it's
like something from Kingsman you're
walking in and there are tailors who are
there you're working with you to pick
all the variations on the suit and make
it look its best you can pick the
material you pick the color it's just
awesome and then you submit your
measurements choose your customizations
and you wait for your custom suit to
arrive in just a few weeks you can also
do it from home this week my listeners
can get any premium in Ticino suit for
just 379 bucks at endo chino calm on the
answer promo code shapiro a check out
that's 50% off the regular price from a
to measure premium suit shipping is free
as well endo chino comm promo code
shapiro again any premium suit for just
379 bucks and free shipping best suit I
own is an Indo Chino suit it's very cool
I even have a vest for it hey endo Chino
compro MacLeod shapiro any premium suit
again 379 bucks and free shipping use
that promo code shapiro
so they know that we sent you again
everything from indígenas gonna be
better than anything you're gonna get
off the rack
okay so meanwhile in other news today
bill cosby has now been convicted which
i think is a good thing obviously Bill
Cosby was accused of essentially
drugging and raping
dozens of women and there's 62 known
women the conviction was about will
I guess the the was about to andrea
constand so he was found guilty on three
counts of sexual assault against andrea
constand
and a bunch of people were celebrating
this one of his alleged victims as a
woman in lily Bernard and and she talked
about sexual assault and the Cosby
verdict here's what she had to say I
stand here in the spirit of Martin
Luther King who said that the arc of the
universe is long but today it has bent
towards justice last year when I was
sitting in the courtroom of the first
trial and the verdict was hung I left
with such a tremendous sense of
disappointment and it became evident to
me that the justice system his light
years behind modern culture but today
this jury has shown that the me - what
the me - movement has saying is that
women are worthy of being believed
obviously I think this is a very good
thing I think it's the the evidence
against Bill Cosby was quite strong
there are some people who dissent they
say well as a he-said she-said right but
there's a lot of credibility when you
have this many victims who can testify
against Bill Cosby and it's the same
story over and over and over and over
again it's also important to note here
that this is the kind of stuff that
meets who was made for right me too was
not made for the woman who says that she
went on a date with a guy and she had
sex with a guy and then she felt bad
later it's not made for a cat person you
know that essay from The New Yorker and
the woman who said that she gave every
signal to the guy that she want to have
sex with him and then she cut him off on
texting and then he was mean to her and
this is like a me-too moment you know
it's not made for stormy Daniel stormy
Daniels is not a me-too story his stormy
Daniels was not sexually assaulted she
was not sexually harassed stormy Daniels
had consensual sex of President Trump
okay what means who was made for was
cases like this where women are abused
and then silenced and stays silent and
then when they come forward on mass then
the question is do we believe them or
not and the answer is that yeah what we
should believe them
especially when they when the supporting
evidence is there now there's another
issue with Bill Cosby here that I think
is worth noting and that is that
obviously Bill Cosby is famous because
he was the biggest television star on
television maybe in television history
The Cosby Show was one of the big hits
in the history of TV and of course he
was the first so
not one method first but he was one of
the the one of the first major black
characters to be portrayed not as a
blue-collar guy but as a white-collar
diner he's a doctor and cliff Huxtable
was a icon for millions of Americans and
made the implicit promise that if you
worked hard in America you could
actually get ahead they're a bunch of
people who are trying to throw the baby
out with the bathwater now saying that
you should never watch The Cosby Show
again or cliff Huxtable as a character
was a terrible thing Wesley Morris at
the New York Times writes a piece today
he says if a sexual predator wanted to
come up with a smokescreen for his
ghastly conquest he couldn't do better
than cliff Huxtable cliff was the
affable patient wise and we're mrs.
Huxtable was concerned justly
deferential his wit was quick his
sweaters roomy and kaleidoscopic he
could be romantic cliff should have been
the envy of any father ever to appear on
a sitcom he was vert a vertiginous Lee
dad Lee okay
cliff is the reason for the cognitive
dissonance we've been experiencing the
last three or four years
he seemed inseparable from the man who
portrayed him and then he suggests that
the Huxtables were wonderful Bill Cosby
was of course not
and he says that the the hard thing
about this verdict is the sorting of the
irony's has been left to us mr. Cosby
may blackness palatable to a country
historically conditioned the worst of
black people to pull that off yet to
find a morally impeccable presentation
of himself and his race but mr. Cosby
may have made it might have managed to
pull a fast one using his power and
wealth to become the predator the white
America mythologized in a campaign to
terrorize torture and kill black people
for a century mr. Cosby told lots of
jokes this was his sickest one if you
really think that a lot of people are
going to throw away the image of cliff
Huxtable because of Bill Cosby I think
that's completely wrong people watch TV
they identify with the characters not
with the actors so the evils of Bill
Cosby do not elite do not I think in any
way suddenly the character of cliff
Huxtable who after all was a character
on TV I think people are smart enough to
recognize that okay meanwhile there is a
there's a lot of hubbub today over the
situation in North Korea soap in a
historic moment because the the dictator
of North Korea Kim jong-un who is indeed
a human piece of debris just a piece of
crap who's been for he and his family
for three generations now have been
forcibly imprisoning millions of people
in a giant gulag
the average South the average South
Korean is I believe three inches taller
than the average North Korean despite a
common genetic heritage because of
malnutrition and starvation
in North Korea hundreds of thousands of
people in North Korea have been passed
through prison camps hundreds of
thousands of people have starved to
death over the tenure of the Kim family
while kim jeong-hoon met with the the
new prime minister new president of
south korea and this was a historic
moment because this is the first time
that anyone from North Korea has
actually stepped across the border of
South Korea for a long time
the South Korean president is moon
jae-in he's a member of what they call
sunshine cabinet which means that they
want to make a deal with North Korea Kim
jong-un finally crossed the border and
this is being hailed as a historic
moment for diplomatic relations between
the two countries but as we look at this
picture it cannot be overstated
the historic nature of what we are
witnessing now these pictures coming to
us outside the peace house on the
southern side of the Demilitarized Zone
that divides the two countries there you
see the two leaders of North Korea and
South Korea shaking hands in a
demonstration of certainly attempted
unity here okay so people think this is
like a major step forward and seeing a
lot of people today celebrating
president Trump saying president from
made this happen okay
now president Trump has been very harsh
with the North Koreans I think that is a
good thing they're feeling the pressure
the Chinese have in turn been very harsh
with the North Koreans which is a good
thing I think they're feeling the
pressure the real truth here is that the
reason that Kim jong-un is shaking the
hand of moon jae-in is because moon
jae-in is dedicated to the idea that he
wants to get American troops off South
Korean soil if he can and he and Kim
Jong Un's share that priority moon
jae-in is a guy who is of the South
Korean left he is very much of the idea
that that Kim Jong Un's should retain
power he wants to make nice with Kim
Jong hoon in other words Kim's news
agency said earlier Friday the leader
would open heartedly discuss with moon
all the issues arising in improving
inter-korean relations moon senior
spokesman said Kim joked that he would
make sure not to interrupt moon sleep
any more apparently referring to the
North the North's series of early
morning missile tests last year
according to CBS News moon spokesman
says Kim also made a reference to South
Korean island that became a target of
the North Korean artillery attack that
killed 4 in 2010 Kim says the residents
of Yong Pyong Island who have been
living under the fear of North Korean
artillery attacks and also families
separated by the 19
52:53 korean war have high hopes for the
inter-korean talks to help he'll pass
cars apparently they're going to sign a
formal end to the Korean War
that does not mean demilitarization of
course and a lot of people again hailing
this as a giant victory I am somewhat
more skeptical so before I explain why
I'm somewhat more skeptical I first
wanted to give you a brief history of
the Korean War because people really
don't know very much about this war they
tend to forget this war it's a forgotten
war in the United States I'm like the
Vietnam War which is of course
championed by the left is an example of
America losing and they think that's
great or World War two which is an
example of the United States intervening
and to stop a genocide the Korean War is
largely forgotten even though the United
States lost tens of thousands of troops
in in the Korean War so the Korean War
started because essentially what
happened is after World World War two
the Russians occupied the northern half
of the Korean Peninsula and the United
States occupied the southern half and
then two flunkies at the State
Department drew a parallel the 38th
parallel and they said okay well we're
going to say that above this is North
Korean below this is South Korea was a
completely arbitrary division the
Russians quickly turned North Korea into
a communist proxy state and the United
States was working with the with the
more free market dictatorship that was
existing in South Korea at the time in
1950 thanks to the United States his
failures to stop the rise of communist
China which was largely due to both the
FDR and the Truman administration's then
the the North Koreans walked across the
border they attacked across the border
they sent tens of thousands of troops
across the 38th parallel and the United
States was quickly in Rushton war that's
June 25th 1950 and 75 thousand soldiers
from the North Korean People's Army
poured across the 38th parallel
according to history.com it was the
first military action of the Cold War by
July American troops had entered the war
on South Korea's behalf and North
Koreans backed by the Chinese backed by
the Russians had been pushed all the way
down into the very end of the Incheon
Peninsula then Douglas MacArthur came up
with a brilliant strategy to retake most
of South Korea and restore the
Demilitarized Zone at the 38th parallel
MacArthur wanted to go farther he
actually wanted to attack the Chinese
and go to the the root of the problem
but Truman stopped him and deposed him
in 1953 the war finally came to an end
so in a second I'm going to explain why
it is that I'm skeptical of what's
happening
right now on the Korean Peninsula but
first I want to say thanks to our new
sponsor is over at eHarmony so you've
heard me talk over and over and over
about the fact that values and the
things that actually matter to you are a
better basis for a relationship than
simply you were in a bar and you saw
somebody good-looking and you decided to
form a relationship with that person
hey eHarmony makes sure that you're
going to have deep and abiding
relationships these are real people
finding real matches with you harmony
there's a reason to people like Lisa and
Mark say we never thought we meet
somebody online so compatible we're so
grateful we were able to find each other
see harmony is built to help you find
those lasting meaningful relationships
is not for shallow hookups okay they use
decades of science and data and
psychological research to send you the
right match the right matches and they
are the number one most trusted dating
site or app based out of 2018 survey of
singles again right now my listeners can
actually get a free month with the
harmony when they sign up for a
three-month subscription to enter my
code then at checkout so you go to
eHarmony and at checkout use promo code
Ben I'm looking at a list of their
questions right now and I can honestly
say that these are questions that it
doesn't take that long do and they
actually go to issues like values I mean
they're asking you things like how
important are your personal religious
beliefs are you somebody who likes to
order and regularity or not are you
somebody who is a listener or are you
somebody who tends to tends to talk more
do you feel better when you're around
other people right these are all
personality questions and there are ways
that they can match you up with people
who are most compatible with you so if
you're looking for a deep long long
lasting real relationship harmony is for
you so stop waiting start your journey
to that relationship and again stop
playing with the stupid dating apps and
go to the ones that are better go to
eharmony.com see harmonies come get
started again enter my code Ben at
checkout and you get a special deal you
get a free month with the Harmony when
you sign up for a three-month
subscription a harmony com get started I
know personally couples that have met
through e harmony go to eHarmony calm
get started right now again enter promo
code Ben at checkout okay so and why am
i skeptical of what is happening in
North Korea the reason I'm skeptical is
because there are lots of these sorts of
historic meetings and some of them end
well and some of them do not end well
there are lots of cases in which the
West has been played in situations like
this so here's what could go wrong in
this meeting what could go wrong is that
moon jae-in and kim jeong-hoon come to
an agreement and the agreement is that
Kim Jong Moon is going to denuclearize
the peninsula he's going to stop
developing nuclear
or he's gonna quote-unquote give up his
nuclear weapons there's no real way that
he's gonna do a verification regime that
it was that allows for anything like
that
and moon jae-in says well in return for
that we don't need the American troops
here anymore because if we do if we do
move denuclearize the peninsula then we
don't need the American trigger force
that bring the United States into the
war because obviously you're not gonna
nuke us if there's a conventional war
there's a conventional war I guess but
we have warm relations so we're really
not too worried about a conventional war
now which point President Trump who has
been saying over and over and over that
he wants to get troops home and out of
places like South Korea he says okay you
know what we'll go along with that we'll
remove the troops from South Korea and
the next thing you know we have a replay
of the Korean War in which the North
Koreans say okay well now that the
Americans aren't here let's start making
some moves on the border let's see if we
can push that border further south let's
see if we can launch a sneak attack
that's a possibility especially given
the instability of the North Korean
regime in fact they are resource short
because they're a giant gulag state
that's a serious problem and there is a
history of this sort of thing many of
the meetings that have been championed
by the West among historic belligerents
have ended incredibly poorly I'm not
even talking about the Alta conference
in which the United States and Russia
and and Britain basically got played by
Russia basically Stalin played Churchill
and played FDR and the United States
gave up far too much in the Aalto
agreement leading to things like the
Korean War leading to the rise of a
powerful USSR that had half of Europe
under its thumb but it's not just issues
like that it's also for example we don't
know whether this is a big incident
moment or whether this is a yasser
arafat's carbine moment so in 1980
menachem order 1979 malcolm Bagan met
with Anwar Sadat Anwar Sadat was the
dictator of Egypt and he met with
Menachem Bagan and he was later
assassinated for doing this but the deal
they came to is that Israel would give
up the Sinai Peninsula at least parts of
the Sinai Peninsula and in return Egypt
would sign a basic peace agreement with
Israel and they'd leave each other alone
and that peace is actually lasted now
for 40 years so that was a good
agreement but I remember all the way
back to 1993 when on the one of the
White House yet chakra bead was shaking
hands and the Israeli prime minister was
shaking hands with an actual terrorist
Yasser Arafat an evil terrorist one of
the worst terrorist of the 20th century
and Yasser Arafat then used the
concessions that he had gained from
Israel backed by the United States in
order to
a series of violence attacks against
Israel that has lasted to the present
day that has not resulted in any sort of
lasting peace it's actually led to the
rise of terrorist groups like Hamas
Islamic Jihad the Palestinian Authority
which is still a terrorist group and led
by now Mahmoud Abbas is the Pratt is the
is the next step in the evolution of
Yasser Arafat's terror group and that
obviously didn't solve anything and I
remember I'm old enough to remember I
was thing not the time I'm old enough to
remember them shaking hands and media
swooning oh look at this it's finally
happening Oh peace is gonna come to the
Middle East peace didn't come to the
Middle East because there were no common
interests so the question is is the West
gonna take a strong stand and require
things of Kim jong-un in this peace or
is this Joyce going to be Kim Jong Un's
latest move in order to get a bunch of
concessions from the West and in return
the West gets very little right the West
gets a promise and this is exactly what
happened with Iran okay the United
States made a deal with Iran and now we
are stuck with that deal with Iran at
least for the foreseeable future because
Barack Obama decided it was more
important to have the photo-op between
the the Iranian Foreign Minister and
John Kerry than it was to actually
uphold sanctions against an evil State
on the brink of nuclear destruction on
the brink of having nuclear weaponry the
the jcpoa the the Iran deal is such a
disaster and you can see that this is
this could be a similar disaster you
could see a situation in which the
United States or South Korea offers a
very similar deal to the North Koreans
and everybody proclaims victory and
within five years the North Koreans are
back making their nuclear weapons except
this time there are no troops on the
South Korean Peninsula it could be a
disaster I'm not saying it will be a
disaster maybe it works out great but
before everybody says this is a
wonderful thing look what Trump has
wrought let's wait to see the result hey
people shaking hands and doing photo ops
is not natural result now that said the
media if this had been under Obama
would've been fawning over it would mean
oh my God look what Obama has done it's
so great they said this about the Iran
deal and it does demonstrate the the
lack of veracity in the media or at
least the lack of credibility in the
media the media are so biased that Trump
gets no mention in what is in fact a
historic summit that's happening between
the two Koreas but by the same token
they would have been orgasming over over
this if this had been President Obama no
question still I you know as he as a
conservative I'm just
saying it might be worthwhile to
withhold judgment for just a little bit
now meanwhile James Comey appeared last
night with Bret bear and James Comey
just looks worse and worse if you're a
Democrat you have to think at this point
that James Comey needs to be put to the
side because he is not helping your case
in the slightest
over and over James Comey made
contentions last night that were just
unsupportable so this one actually I
believe is not on Fox News he was he was
asking how how possibly on CNN he was
asking how can trump supporters explain
to their grandchildren that they traded
the rule of law for tax cuts this is
James Comey doing his best virtue
signaling on CNN then he meets Bret
Baier and things go wildly wrong for him
my question for the Republicans is so
where is that where is that commitment
to character and values and if if people
have convinced themselves well we'll
trade it temporarily for a tax cut or
Supreme Court justice as I say in the
book that's a fool's bargain because
those values are all that you have
they'll always be another Supreme Court
justice always another tax bill you lose
this exactly what are you yeah again
this sort of language
well then they've traded rule of law for
tax cuts have any Republicans said that
rule of law should not be upheld here
there are Republicans who have said they
will vote for impeachment if Robert
Muller is fired Jeff Sessions has been
standing for the rule of law I really
believe that Jeff Sessions has said if
you get rid of Rod Rosenstein I will
leave too so I'll take off and none of
this suggests that the Republicans have
abandon rule of law but James Comey
identifies himself with rule of law and
therefore he is the the only person that
ought to be listened to obviously then
he goes on Bret Baier and things go
wildly wrong for him yeah so this is
this this this whole perspective of
James Comey is great law bringer goes
completely by the wayside because it
turns out James Comey doesn't know
basics about his about his own behavior
right so James Comey testified that he
handed over material to a friend of his
that was probably classified to hand out
to the media and he's asked about by
bret baier did you leak watch James
Comey around for an answer so the
story of that briefing leaks out almost
immediately after you do at CNN and
others run the story of this unverified
dossier did you or your subordinates
leaked that no did James clapper no not
to my knowledge
you know John Brennan I I don't know who
leaked it I had no part in any leaking
of it it was about four or five days
later that it leaked but I remember cuz
President Elect called me about it do
you ever try to find out who leaked an
unclassified public document no ma did
he try apparently he never tried to find
out who leaked the news of him informing
Trump of the dossier to the press which
was used as the news hook by BuzzFeed to
actually released the entire dossier no
he never bothered to look into that he
was also asked did you leak write did
you leak when you when you leaked after
your firing all of your memos your
friend was data leak and he said well I
don't think so I mean I don't know and
Bret Baier was like well it kind of was
wasn't it and that sort of the
definition of a leak and Comey had no
answer for that Comey admitted that he
said he didn't know who the Democrats
funded the Steele dossier which is
insane of course he knew the Democrats
funded that Steele dossier watch him
futz around on this one yeah I still
don't know that for a fact
what do you mean I've only seen it in
the media I never knew exactly which
Democrats had funded I knew it was
funded first by Republicans of the Lucid
oh I'm sorry that's not true that the
dossier that Christopher Steele worked
on was funded by Republicans my
understanding was his work started
funded by Oppo Ria's Oppo research
funded by Republicans so free beacon and
said that they had Glenn Simpson
infusion GPS on a kind of a retainer but
they did not fund the Christopher Steele
memo or the dossier that was initiated
by Democrats okay my understanding was
the activity was begun that the steel
was hired to look into was first funded
by Republicans then picked up the
important thing was picked up by
Democrats opposed to Donald Trump's okay
so I like how even here he's futzing
around I mean he really looks bad last
night and well he should have because he
again is making a fool of himself the
fact of media keep trotting him out I
think they were undercutting their own
credibility here okay so in just a
second I'm gonna get into the mailbag
because it is mailbag time here at the
ben shapiro show but first you're gonna
have to go over to daily wire right now
and you're gonna have to subscribe for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription to
daily wire that means you get the rest
of our show live you get the rest of the
Michael Noel's show live you get the
rest of the end room Clavin show live it
also means right now apparently our
daily wire news site is is now being
featured at the Apple Store so you can
go to the Apple app it's the Apple news
right Apple news it's now parent
the wire appears on Apple news so go
check that out as well please and if you
want the annual subscription then you
get this be very greatest in all
beverage vessels the leftist here is hot
or cold tumbler you will love every
second of it because it is magnificent
it is just great also right now it's
gonna be part of the mailbag now is a
great time to subscribe spend the next
30 seconds subscribing can ask me
questions live in the mailbag which will
be doing presently you just want to
listen later for free go over to iTunes
go over to SoundCloud subscribe with
this review YouTube particularly please
subscribe please leave this review we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
already so mailbag times let's jump
right in
so Alex says hi Ben with Paul Ryan gone
next term who'd you like to see is
Speaker of the House also who would you
like to see as a majority leader of the
Senate thanks and love the show so a
Speaker of the House I I do like Jim
Jordan I think Jim Jordan would be very
good at that role you do need somebody
who's going to be militant particularly
because they have to stand up to both
Mitch McConnell if they're in the
majority or the Democrats if they're in
the minority yeah I think that Paul Ryan
is is a wonk I think that he's a guy who
is yeah I think he knows what he
believes I think that he is a principled
person but I think that he's in the
wrong position if you're the head of the
the House Majority or if you're the
house Minority you have to be a knife
fighter somebody who's willing to
manipulate you have to be somebody who's
willing to get dirty I don't think Ryan
is necessarily that guy you have to be
able to exert leverage on your own
members which Ryan obviously was not
willing to do you also at some point
have to stand up to your own Senate if
the Senate won't do it and say listen
we're not gonna pass anything right
Mitch if you don't want the blame
falling on you you're gonna have to do
better I'm not sure that Paul Ryan did
that a whole hell of a lot I think Jim
Jordan would so I like the idea of Jim
Jordan as Majority Leader or as a
speaker of the house or as Minority
Leader mark says as far as sorry a
majority leader of the Senate I think
that you know senator Cruz has made a
has made a good case for why he should
be majority leader of the Senate I think
there are probably some less
controversial figures who would be
similarly good I mean I'd love to see
Mike Lee as majority leader of the
Senate but they're all my favorite
senators I'd like to see his majority
leader of the Senate because I think
those people would hold the line a
little bit better than Mitch McConnell
has McConnell is a deal guy right he's a
guy who kind of he in the future he'll
be seen more as a Tip O'Neill type you
know I sort of got things done by using
his various methodologies but I'm not
sure that Mitch McConnell is is a lot to
speak about when it comes to principled
leadership Mark's has been a few days
ago Jordan Peterson said bill to ask
Bill Maher's panel if Trump is impeached
what are your plans to heal the rift
between the left and the right of course
they didn't answer his question so if
Trump is impeached how could the rift be
healed well it depends what he's
impeached over so if Trump were actually
impeached over something that's
legitimate let's say the Trump committed
an actual crime as president of the
United States a serious crime as
president of the United States and he is
in page then the rift would be healed by
Mike Pence coming forward
president and saying listen criminal
activity is not acceptable on either
side of the aisle and the left saying
you know what you're right we're good
now right that's the way that this would
be healed if he's impeach for no reason
right if he's impeached because
Democrats hate him it's gonna be very
difficult to rectify that breach because
Republicans are rightly going to say the
Democrats have been misusing the tools
of government in order to go after
particular people they don't like in
government which only exacerbates the
the belief the Democrats should never
ever have the reins of government now
there is a conciliation possible there
too and that is both sides eventually
acknowledge that there should be no
power of government over a wide variety
of issues because we can't trust the
other side with the power and a
libertarian consensus in other words you
can see that happening but I think that
that's a little ways away and I don't
think this cast of characters Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi Donald Trump Mitch
McConnell think this this cast of
characters is capable of getting that's
done be Tate says hey Ben
is it possible to rely too heavily on
Teta to support an argument in a world
chock-full of data to support both sides
of an argument why is there still so
much separation and thought between the
right and the left seems to me it seems
like one can quote data or research but
nobody really cares
seems the values are more important than
data used to support them I think that's
usually true an argument and this is why
I like to argue first principles data
can be used to support first principles
but I think that most people are
convinced on the basis of moral
argumentation and first principles
arguments not on the basis of data but
the data you have to support your first
principles so data are necessary bulwark
for a good argument but I'm not sure the
data themselves make the argument data
can provide the foundation for an
argument but even below that foundation
there is a bedrock and the bedrock is
the value system that you're trying to
promote Joe says hey Ben my brother
thinks the United States is not the best
country in the world he refers to the UN
human development ranking in Clemson
Norway is a better country than the
United States how would you counter his
argument considering he's actually
loaded with statistics okay so first of
all Norway is living on the basis of an
extraordinary an externally large oil
fine and they've been living off the
basis of that oil production for a long
time I did an entire episode where I
discuss what Norway's economy looks like
second of all Norway is essentially
ethnically homogenous there's not a lot
of ethnic diversity in Norway so
claiming that Norway is better than the
United States
you have to consider the kind of folks
who are living in Norway and then you
have to say well is it really
operable even you'd also have to look at
for example the level of economic
mobility in places like Norway without
state intervention you have to look at
the the fact that the United States is
the most powerful economy on earth if
the United States did not exist would
normally still be a powerful country
economically the answer is no yeah again
is it possible that you'd enjoy living
in Norway more than the United States
only if you enjoy 60% taxes and living
in a small apartment but is it possible
that you'd like Norway better maybe I
mean if that's what floats your boat if
that's what floats your boat but to
suggest that Norway's for example more
tolerant than the United States they
don't have to deal with the same
problems that the United States does in
terms of trying to integrate so many
different ethnicities that's both a
problem and a Gloria and a wonderful
thing about the United States obviously
is Norway better than the United States
in terms of the economy again not if you
want to get rich is Norway better than
the United States in terms of when the
treatment of individuals you'd have to
talk to the various individuals involved
I treat people as individuals I think
some individuals in Norway probably have
it tough some individuals in the United
States probably have it tough so you'd
have to actually look at which metric
you're talking about if you're talking
about GDP per capita in Norway is higher
than the United States that's easy to
verify but again a lot of that is based
on the government essentially gathering
an enormous amount of oil and then
putting all the money from it into a
state pension fund a house has been
private specific charities exist in much
higher numbers than in biblical times do
you still believe we should tithe 10% or
can some of those funds be given to
private charities so my understanding is
that most people who are religious
believe that that when you give to a
private charity that counts as part of
your tithing I think so I think that's
it's one of the reasons why I think that
if you're going to have a quote unquote
welfare state in the United States
instead of the government just seizing
an enormous amount of cash from you and
then using it through government means
for redistribution ISM if you're if
you're gonna do something like this you
ought to mandate that people give a
certain amount of their money to charity
and then they should be able to pick the
charity the money goes to okay let's see
david says in a show I was watching
they're referencing the 25th amendment
to remove the president but I read it
only takes away his powers can you
please clarify sure so the 25th
amendment removes the power from the
President to actually to actually become
to actually exercise his power that the
the twenty-fourth amendment says a few
things so section 1 says in the case of
removal of the
president from office or of his death of
resignation then the vice president
becomes president but the part that they
are usually talking about in the in the
25th amendment is the part about if the
president loses his capacity so the
president can regain capacity under the
25th amendment so here's the way that it
works I'll read you the whole thing it
says whenever the vice president and a
majority of either the principal
officers of the executive departments or
such other body as Congress may by law
provide transmit to the president pro
tempore of the Senate and the Speaker of
the House of Representatives their
written declaration that the president
is unable to discharge his duties the
Vice President shall immediately assume
the powers and duties of the office as
acting president so in order for that to
happen the VP and a majority of either
of the principal offices of the
executive departments a majority of the
cabinet and the VP or another body the
Congress has to create have to transmit
a ruling to the President Pro Tem of the
Senate and the Speaker of the House a
declaration that the president is unable
to discharge the duties but if the
president transmit to the President Pro
Tem and the Speaker of the House is
written declaration that there is no
inability then he resumed the powers and
duties of his office unless either the
VP or majority of the principal officers
of the executive department or that body
provided by Congress transmit within
four days to the President Pro Tem or
the Speaker of the House their written
declaration that the president knows it
is unable to discharge the powers and
duties of his office so in other words
VP and cabinet say to Congress president
Trump can't handle it pence becomes
president until Trump sends a note to
Congress saying hey no I'm fine
everything's cool this is just a power
grab at which point they they have it he
has four days to do that and then the VP
well actually he transmitted right way
then the VP and a majority transmit
within four days a another written
declaration that he's unable to
discharge the powers and duties of his
office at that point Congress decides
the issue and they have to assemble
within 48 hours and if the congressman
is within 21 days after the receipt of
the latter written declaration or if
Congress is not in session within 21
days after Congress is required to
assemble determines by two-thirds vote
of both houses the president is able is
unable to discharge the powers and
duties of his office
then the VP continues to discharge the
same as Acting President so in other
words the president doesn't become not
the president he's just incapacitated
for the period in which he's
incapacitated okay but it takes a
two-thirds vote of each house to
actually
declare the president incapacitated to
the level that he cannot regain his
power if he attempts to regain his power
Marx has been with Bill Cosby being
found guilty should we still appreciate
his contribution to comedy in the same
way we appreciate past presidents for
their accomplishments not their faults
or is this situation different so mark
as I said earlier on the show I do think
we should appreciate his contributions
to comedy I'm not somebody who believes
that the art is completely inseparable
from the artist there have been lots of
awful people who've been great artists
lots of awful people who have created
great human developments and we should
recognize their great human developments
and we should also recognize what awful
people they were so I love the comedy
particularly the early comedy of Bill
Cosby I think in Cosby shows a great
show I still think that listening to his
albums is okay and I still think that
he's a piece of crap so I think all of
these things can be held true at the
same time how many comics by the way are
not pieces of crap as it turns out it
turns out a lot of them really are Frank
says dear Ben do you have any advice for
future musicians or actors who want to
be public with their conservative
opinions big fan of the show well my
first advice is if you want to be
successful apparently you have to remain
silent up till the point where you're
successful then you can come out as
conservative and be okay that's at least
the rule in Hollywood if you start off
as conservative you're shutting an
enormous number of doors unless you're
in the music industry like the country
music industry but even Shania Twain
gets raked over the coals if she says
she's gonna back Trump unfortunately we
live in a system in which people are
routinely discriminated against on the
basis of their politics so I think that
it is well worthwhile for you to keep
your politics as close to the best as
possible until you are successful enough
that you don't have to worry about the
blowback right Kanye is not really gonna
have to worry about the blowback but
that's cuz Kanye is Kanye okay Rachael
says hi Ben should parents be required
under threat of losing custody to
subject their children to chemotherapy
if the child has a cancer diagnosis and
the prevailing medical advice
treatment is chemo thanks Rachel so my
answer is I believe yes because I do
think that there is a difference between
doctors deciding that they have
life-saving treatment they want to
provide to a child and the parents
saying no and parents deciding that they
want their child to live and doctors
saying no right this is the alfie Evans
cases the reverse alfie Evans cases
parents saying we think we can save the
kid and the doctors say no you can he
has to die which is evil but you know
then this is a case that comes up a lot
with regard to there's certain parents
who say they don't want their kids to
have medical treatment for simple
diseases and I mean we're not even
talking about chemo
for cancer but their parents will say
that they don't want kids to have simple
blood transfusions because they think
that it violates certain principles and
the kid will die without the blood
transfusion to me that's child
endangerment and at that point the state
has the right to say you don't get to
decide for your kid that your kid has to
die Skye's has been I'm a tenth grader
and in my history class my teacher asked
what is the common barrier to modern-day
democracy in America most people said
racism and sexism what is your opinion
well I think that the biggest barrier to
if we're gonna say first of all I don't
think there's a barrier to modern-day
democracy I think America is a republic
and people vote in that republic and
there are no serious barriers to people
voting in the United States if the idea
is what's the barrier to us all getting
along and they said racism and sexism I
would say tribalism more than racism or
sexism I don't think that women are
being barred from office I don't think
black people are being barred from
office we had a black president we
almost had a female president and we've
had we've had female secretaries of
state several times there are many
female members of the Supreme Court and
they're black members of the Supreme
Court I don't think the racism and
sexism are the biggest obstacles to the
country at this point Stephen says hey
man I'm trying to think of a question to
submit to the mailbag but I can't think
of one what should I ask well dude you
made it so apparently you didn't have to
submit a good question good for you and
thanks to my producers for putting that
up there you jerks clay says hi Ben I've
been a listener for over a year now and
you've been very influential in my
beliefs about conservatism I've spoken
out a lot this year during my college
classes either during student
presentations or unsolicited professor
virtue signaling when I hear a student
or teachers start going off about
leftist ideology am i obligated as a
conservative to provide the counter to
that opinion so long as I'm well-versed
in research also when you plan on having
Kanye on the show regards quite well hey
I'd have Kanye on the show today I mean
I think that'd be a lot of fun and in a
little while I will tell you all about
my inculcation into rap and how I got
into rap but first but as far as whether
you're obligated no you're never
obligated to say anything with regard to
your politics I think that you know as a
moral human being
you should probably speak up when you
are capable of speaking up but if you
are in a situation where your grades are
going to suffer I never tell students
that is their job to lose a grade
because they have to speak up to no
apparent purpose okay final question and
then we'll do a thing I like emotion
says hi Ben if we get self-driving cars
in the future should we allow law
enforcement to override the cars
computer to bring people with warrants
out for their arrest of the police
station does an unconvicted person with
an arrest warrant have a right to avoid
being arrested
well no I mean if they have the right to
break into your house to effectuate an
arrest warrant then they have the right
to take control of your car and bring
you home
interesting idea by the way very very
very Minority Report so I kind of kind
of like this okay so time for a quick
thing I like and then we'll do a quick
thing that I hate so thing I likes as I
said earlier this week jokingly on
Twitter I am now apparently a rap maven
because Kanye West everyone on the right
has now been legally obligated to like
rap because Kanye West has come out and
said that he likes president Trump I'm
just joking of course I still think rap
is largely garbage but my first
inculcation draft the first the first
song that really brought me I think into
the world of R&B and rap and and all of
it I think was probably this particular
song it's just an amazing example
example of the true artistry and verbal
acuity of so many of our nation's
rappers what's amazing about this
particular music video aside from the
fact that Weird Al is the best the best
okay is that if you actually go back and
watch the gangster's paradise video
there there's so many great references
to it so the best reference of course in
the in the gangster's paradise video it
shows I can't remember which rapper did
does gangster's paradise
I can't even sorry who is it Coolio
thank you so there's there's a close-up
shot in profile of Coolio sweating right
as the song goes on he starts to sweat
more and more because it's so intense
and so weird al' throughout the song
there there cutaway shots of him in
profile and he just starts sweating it's
like pouring off his face just like from
airplane it's just great okay so I will
say this about Weird Al Weird Al is one
of the great unappreciated artists of
our time and Weird Al Yankovic is the
best all of his songs are better than
the originals all of them okay if you
have a choice between listening to Amish
paradise and gangster's paradise Amish
paradise is significantly better if you
have a choice between listening to the
actual Hamilton soundtrack and listening
to Weird Al's mashup on accordion of the
Hamilton soundtrack it is much better
okay Weird Al is much better he's
actually a pretty good musician and he's
really really funny so yeah this is what
got me into rap also white and nerdy
which is just spectacular so kudos to
weird
is not a racial thing if we're doubt
we're black I would still love his stuff
okay so that's just kind of like white
rappers I think I'm a times yeah I
disliked I'm a nothing but you know
Weird Al's the best though I have no
more words okay this is this was this is
it this how I got into rap Weird Al
Yankovic okay time for some things that
I hate so Republicans in Congress just
because people are popular on the
interwebs okay just because people are
popular on the interwebs Republicans in
Congress does not mean that you actually
have to have them to Congress to say
silly things so diamond and silk are
very popular on the interwebs a diamond
in silicon of course sisters who are
black and are big fans of President
Trump they gained a lot of what kind of
credibility on the right because they
were so Pro Trump and because they're
conservative in some ways well they had
said that Facebook had shut down their
page and prevented them from
distributing their message there is a
fair bit of counselor evidence to
suggest that that may not in fact be
wholly the case what they say is that
they've reached out to Facebook Facebook
didn't reach out to them Facebook says
we did reach out to them and they've
ignored us okay listen I think the
Facebook algorithm change is a disaster
and I think that it is at least in part
politically motivated even if the people
who made it don't believe that it's
politically motivated but diamond and
silk were testifying before Congress and
at one point they were it was asked
about them it was asked of them whether
they had been paid by the Trump
administration at any point of the Trump
campaign at any point the answer is yes
okay according to FEC filings diamond
and silk were paid about 1200 bucks at
some point during the campaign time and
in silk instead tonight this under oath
which is in fact perjury and you can
just see this thing just went sideways
right out the gate wrong way I think you
stated on the record today at least
three times quote we were not paid by
the Trump campaign is that correct that
is okay now are you aware that your
testimony today is under oath subject to
the penalty of perjury yes we are aware
that okay now the FEC report dated May
12 2017 states that on November 22nd
2016 the campaign of Donald J Trump for
president incorporated hey I'm in
Silke mm-hmm 1,200 $74.95 for field
consulting mm-hmm are you familiar with
that we're familiar with that particular
line we could see that you do look at
fake news what happened is and what
should have happened is you should have
come to our mouths to see what exactly
happens right before a false narrative
was put out there about the 1274 dollars
in 94 cents so let me explain right now
to you and hold on one second because I
want to give you the opportunity to
explain which is why I'm asking the
question right I'm actually trying to
figure are you calling this FEC document
fake well actually let me get some no
we're not called an opportunity to
respond okay I'm just really trying I'm
struggling I'm really just trying to
figure out right because you have an FEC
document that clearly indicates that the
two of you were paid for field
consulting by the Trump campaign that's
just one document there may be others
that out here and presumably this was a
document filed with genuineness and
authenticity by the campaign of the
president that you so love and so I'm
just trying to figure out we understand
is lying here is it the Trump campaign
or no not so they claim that Facebook
censored them for six months they say
the answer yes when they were blocked
and asked if they were blocked on
Facebook it's not clear they were
blocked on Facebook the algorithm may
have been used to demote them on
Facebook which is not quite the same
thing and they said we have never been
paid by the Trump campaign except that
they were paid in fact by the Trump
campaign and then when they were asked
about the FEC filing by the Trump
campaign they called it fake news guys
just because people are famous on the
internet does not mean that they are
great for the conservative cause on
every issue I think diamond and silk can
say some really great stuff some really
effective stuff but this is not the
place to be doing it it just I thought
the this is an entire hearing that the
backfired in pretty significant fashion
okay other things that I hate so Tom
Brokaw has now been accused of sexual
misconduct or rather on Brokaw has been
accused of very weird hardman apparently
he's been accused of sexually harassing
Linda Wester who's of course the famous
war correspondent variety said Brokaw
physically tried to force her to kiss
him on two separate occasions
groped her in an NBC conference room and
showed up at her home
tell room uninvited and apparently
there's another allegation against
brocro from an anonymous woman I have to
say dudes famous dudes what in the world
what okay like why is that every famous
dude for the last 30 years apparently
his on TV has been groping women they
can pretty much name on one hand that
people have not been accused of things
over the last thirty years it's just
incredible and it goes to show you that
all of the of the leftist posturing
about how they are not sexist how many
of these people are on the left a lot of
people are on the left all of which
suggests that human nature there are a
lot of men who give in to the the human
nature of being horrible to women and
that's why you need a civilization
filled with men who are trained not only
not to do these things but also to
protect women is why the leftist view
that that being on the left somehow
makes you a pure human being put your
politics define your purity is a human
being this is not true and it's
something the right has never actually
believed okay so we'll be back here on
Monday with much much more i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis lover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018